Here is our filled out table. Now, of course we don't want to be dependent on
calculators for everything, but they certainly do come in handy when we have
calculations that end up giving us huge numbers, like 3,125. You can see this
only at a value of x equals 5. Imagine if I had given you even higher x values.
Our numbers for h of x would have been huge. Some of these numbers you
definitely could have figured out by hand or in your head. In fact, you
probably did. Though there might be some on this list you could have done that
way, that you didn't realize. For example, when x equals negative 3, h of x is
5 to the negative 3. This is just equal to 1 over 5 to the 3rd. Five to the
3rd, is 125. So, that's 1 over 125. So this is the fractional of this decimal
over here. This answer is perfectly acceptable, as well. Although, it's
probably not what a calculator will give you, depending on what sort of device
you're using. We can see something similar happening for 5 to the negative 2.
That's just 1 over 5 squared, or 1 over 25.